what's up guys the story in here and we
are here with the legendary boss logic I
am so honored to be in his presence
because he's just a legend in the whole
nerd community everywhere basically so
he's here in LA and we decided to do
some Twitter questions are you are you
ready I'm ready
and before you start so we can't don't
spoil anything but how was the vendors
in-game it's probably my favorite movie
I know comic books aim is intense man
no spoilers so let's just go ahead and
jump to these shorter questions Evan
sundog asked at what age did you start
doing your amazing work and you do now
and when did you realize that you had
such a talent what's up Evan so
basically I started doing traditional
drawings from the age of 9 but then
transition to digital in 2009 and from
then on I started doing my own creations
marina that I transferred into fana five
years later and basically kept doing it
kept grinding till right now I'm still
grinding I'm still learning P B Clark
asked when point fifty-year and what was
the system spec of your first computer
for making digital art and what do you
now and if nobody else asked what are
your favorite art software use so
basically I can't remember my first spec
but what I'm using right now is a Wacom
Pro portable studio just so I can go
around and use it anywhere the software
I use and always use and always will use
is Photoshop so get that if you Diego
MKZ asked how much time did it take you
to finish that portrait and I'm assuming
he means the the amazing poster that you
got to do for morals that one took
initially nine hours to do from start to
finish but plus revisions
it took them around another six hours
all right at Joella blue asked
congratulations first of all which is
your favorite to imagine fictional
characters in their fictional settings
real people boxers etc or actors in the
roles you wish that they aren't in fan
casting this is something I love doing
and sometimes they end up in their roles
and people I say blame me for
that's all right a lot yes spank ass TMJ
93's if both logic had already been
taken what would you call have called
yourself lgx was one of them um
basically it's logics just shortened
yeah but now logic like everyone
confuses both logic with logic the
rapper yeah because it's I got a
verified tick on my account and everyone
just that's me I love your new song I'm
like okay Nick and boss worth he asked
how do you manage your time so well I'm
creating all this amazing artwork on a
such a consistent basis my timekeeping
sucks man that's like I don't sleep
sometimes it's not healthy that's like I
I got a fund of balance we all everybody
trying to find a balance I you create
your own continent still I'm crazy it's
crazy all right we got at Dennis liber
bases but he asked what was what's your
favorite working doing my favorite work
non non comic book related is coming
with the rain that's a it's a water
piece that I did and comic book related
would have to be the last short my face
electric under 4df ask if you weren't
drawing what else would you be doing
well
Odia nearing was one of my first things
I used to like creating baits I sucked
at it but I still loved it but I'll
probably would have pursued that Seiler
TV ask any tips for aspiring artists for
digital art like yourself basically
don't get discouraged
like putting your work out there just
keep going there'll be a lot of people
hating you and like this in your work
but keep grinding and keep going
nothing nothing good comes with a
consistence things just keep going for
the last question at Kobe underscore
quaza BZ ask what Marvel character are
you looking forward to making an artwork
one that hasn't been introduced on
screen yet well MCU magneto more that's
what on oh man alright please get on
that okay but I just want to say thank
you the game ball so it
when I'm not kidding when I said it's an
honor to be like I've been following
your career for years so to see like
there was grinding and out here and
being able to like do work for Marvel
Studios I think that's just awesome man
so thank you for the whole community
he's very he's very high really nice
meeting you too dude
alright guys make sure like subscribe
we'll see you later for more content